ジャパ
二世が公民にいく快感がで一生寝てるすぐ入って来いこんにちははじめしゃちょーで
そういうわけでご覧ください
変回数 sxt ブルードゥチョイっアップニーハイフォッグああっっ
なーん
あの本当に俺が人生行ってきた中で見たことのないくらいの他のチョコエッグ売って
ました
ちょっとすごいよオレが持ってもこのサイズ誤差ですから拉致問題やばいこれどこで
買ったかというとコストコで売ってましたよあと滅茶苦茶売れ残ってました誰も誰も
買ってないんですね
これもって追ってくれてレジン床に行ったら別の人がえっ
このチョコね売れるのを初めて見たアーサーって誰で本当に咲く売れてないんだと思い
ます
だっておいん
6kg て書いてあったけど実際箱合わせるとどれくらいなんでもちょっと測ってみ
ましょうか
さあいきます
入っん
zard なのでしょはい
0格好だけでも8キロぐらいのこれ i 普通のチョコエッグとの比較です居然たい
人間ですね
コストパッって粉を面白商品作るところだっけ
こんなふざけてる鳥見たことないんですけど左側を上げていきたいとおもいます
おっ
ほっうわぁほんっ
[音楽]
ほっっも覚えなにこれ
ああ
ブーブーって
うわーん
ああああああ
バッハわっは分
東京てこの輪っかに
うわぁ俺の顔とならネオこのサイズの
されす持ってみた感じですねそんなめちゃくちゃ多いです
何か入ってるのかなんかちょっと何が入ってるかわかんないんですけど早速あげて
みようと思います2の緒が入ってだったら中におもちゃと puffy に入ってると
思うんですけどこれ何が入っているとしたらと任天堂スイッチとかの大きさよこれ
じゃあさっそく開けてみようと思います
はっはっは山としてるわー
うわっハ民セミで見てみなさーん万事でちゃんとチョコ意気なんだけど
おっ
or ならー町のちゃんとしたチョコエッグ山つもっていいかこれいっ
こんなことあるちょっとあってヶ月の時頭は完全チョコ行くですね
goo
ちゃーん全く別の商品名に起きたらチョコエッグはこうやってパカッと言われるんです
よ
こう言って貼って中にこういう感じでおもちゃが入ってるんですけど話お前の中には何
が入ってるんだ
邪念値段22,000円です
パイパンっ
まあやばい
はいやばいっ
えっいいこと聞きました脚本切ってもこれなれないんだこれヤバイっては0
痛いまで同所でしょ本当にこれほどに俺本の未来部硬いです
すればいいんだうッッ
何もないみなさんご覧くださいご覧くださいわかりますでしょうか何も入ってません
やばい
頭突きではれないチョコ初めて見たそれもそのはずなんですよ
チョコナッツさあみてくださいそこらへんの瓦蔵屋ついんですよ
うわぁいやもうすごいよいいよ凄いなぁ
美味しいでも甘い前久三郎
ポン系のが美味しいおやつ頑張って食べないっ
[音楽]
ツイートはやんけどねよくあるパ以外のチョコです
コストコって感じきます
います
2あって中にねチョコの始めたらね音が反響するんですよ
th
いやーすごいよこれマジで丈夫ですこれなんか全然俺も素手でやろうと思いませんで
割る呼ばれるけど多分そこそを気がしますね
入った
[音楽]
ハーフ風味のそうですなった
ブーブー言っ
杉戸と the みんな食べてー
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーブー